let's talk a little bit about sources of
income during retirement so we're
assuming you're retired you're not
working so you're not getting gonna get
that income but one of them is perhaps
just your straight up investment income
you save money over time you've invested
it in let's say dividend paying stocks
the dividend is an income maybe you've
bought rental properties those rents
after paying all the expenses those can
be income but there's also things that
are a special purpose for retirement
probably most common is social security
you pay into Social Security when you
get your paycheck you will see that some
of it is essentially taken out for
Social Security and then when you become
the age where you can start collecting
that Social Security you get a payout
and up to a cap it is related to how
much you have actually paid in to Social
Security
now above and beyond Social Security
many employers will have employee
employer sponsored plans and that is
money that you pay in and oftentimes the
employer will add some money to that
they'll match some percentage of what
you put into that plan for example a
401k and then you can put money into it
on a pre-tax basis so what does that
mean normally let's say you make an
incremental ten thousand dollars and
your marginal tax rate is say 20 percent
well you're going to have to pay two
thousand dollars of tax on that ten
thousand dollars but something like a
401k you could put that ten thousand
dollars into the plan and not have to
pay taxes on it up front and then you
can invest it within the plan you can
find out different types of investment
vehicles ways ways to invest that money
within the plan there's not unlimited
choices but they usually have several
choices within the plan and then when
you're of retirement age you you can
take it out and then you pay taxes now
you might say well I'm going to pay
taxes one way or the other but when you
pay taxes when you're retired one you
deferred those taxes by many years
usually many many decades and also when
you're retired it's prop it's possible
that your income is lower and so your
marginal tax rate is lower and so you
might actually have to pay fewer taxes
on those same dollars so you have social
security you have employee employer
sponsor plans like 401ks and then you
have individual retirement plans the
most common one is it was called an Ira
Ira individual retirement account and
that's an individual plan that you
usually go and get with a bank or broker
on your own it's not connected to an
employer and that there's two types
there's a traditional IRA where similar
to a 401k you can put money in on a
pre-tax basis up to a cap and 401ks also
have a cap you can invest it without
taxes and then some future date you're
going to pay the taxes on it there's
also something called a Roth IRA which
you pay the taxes up front put the money
in but then you can invest it tax-free
and then when you take it out at
retirement you don't have to pay taxes
on it so those those are the the basic
ways that you're going to get income in
your retirement so it's good to start
thinking about them early